there used to be families in every house
on this street you could hear the kids
laughing all the time
what's going on it's cold grandma's out
i left my key inside you hungry you know
we don't need anyone to save us
just trying to save myself
i'm still looking for answers i just
don't know the questions anymore
[Music]
i've got blood on my hands no matter how
hard i try i can't wash away the past
sorry about the smell i'm used to it
for your
trouble good
most guys i sponsored they got a hard
time doing work
but you you got a different sort of
melody yeah it ain't the work it's the
letting go
your grandma's gonna worry you ain't my
father
you find a way to make peace with it
or it makes war with you
shut we closed
i'm gonna have to open you up what
god has a plan
we can never go home kill the girl and
the old lady make it messy i'm gonna
make it right
home protection hunting
[Applause]
the trash trashman wasn't always a trash
man
sent me to kill a grimmed reaper
he said find a way to make peace
[Music]
did
how'd you get this number
same way i got your dress
[Music]
you